Hey so you're here because you want to
know about my problem this is my problem
this has become an actual serious issue
and I'm concerned about my well-being
because there is nothing else that I
want to do except play Zelda breath the
freakin wild thankfully I've been sick
for about a week so in that week time
span I basically spent sleeping eating
and playing Zelda and it's a great thing
because I was actually not physically
well enough to do anything else except
those things that's the problem because
now that I'm feeling better I have to
get back into the real world and tonight
I went out and hung out with real people
and it was it felt weird felt strange
the good news is I can just take the
switch with me but like I tried I tried
to like have just a moment away from it
and I didn't like the moments that I had
away from it but I came home to this the
other problem but I was having is when I
pre-ordered my switch I didn't pre-order
any accessories because I figured let me
get it let me figure out what I want but
by that time they're all sold out
everywhere Game Stop Best Buy Target
like every there's like nothing
thankfully I ordered this one on Amazon
before it became like a three four or
five month wait so we're gonna unbox
this and take a look at it and see what
it's like I was kind of hoping that I
would have a case that would have little
indentations where the joy cons could go
in and that these wouldn't get knocked
around because I do worry about their
their safety and their health and I want
them to be perfect and it doesn't look
like this has that it just kind of looks
like it has a little pocket to like
stick it in now after this I'm gonna
show you guys it's just kind of what
I've been working with some of the armor
that I've got and my map so if you don't
want any spoilers don't watch the end of
this video I won't really give you any
real spoilers so don't worry and me I
don't care I want to know everything so
if there's anything because you want to
tell me about the game to tell me right
below because whatever you tell me I'm
gonna go try to find it immediately I
was definitely hoping it would have a
better better quality feel to it doesn't
feel bad it doesn't feel good I don't
like I don't like this feet it feels dry
[Applause]
it's kind of basic this definitely
wasn't what I was hoping for but it'll
do it'll do for the time being until
more accessories come out it's super
super basic and there's a place to put
all your cards comes with a little
cleaning cloth let's see what it looks
like with the switch in it they have
about 80 or so hours and two Zelda I'm
not sure it doesn't tell you exactly but
on your user profile it'll tell you hey
you've played over so-and-so hours so
it's not 100 was inaccurate but you can
get a good sense I can carry it nicely
just like so there just needs to be some
more options that really wasn't anything
else and I was like I don't want to be
carrying this thing around and have it
damaged because my life right now is on
this another thing I did get which was
also kind of hard to get as well our
extra joy con controllers so you dig in
the gray version and you're like shoot I
wish I had the colored joi cons you can
actually get those but they're sold in
the opposite color of the colored neon
switch which is cool because you can do
something like this switch you can have
an Allred switch or an all blue switch
the blue looks good that looks nice
I feel like this red will definitely
match what I'm wearing me right now so
they had both the right controller and
as you can see on the bottom they have
the IR sensor right there I've really
been enjoying this so much a lot of you
guys I'm telling me to play and post
gameplay and honestly I've said this so
many times before I mean I have a gaming
channel and I at the time when I had my
gaming channel I really enjoyed doing it
and for me now I much rather enjoy
sitting and playing the games and not
having to entertain because it got to be
not as much fun as I used to have what I
would post gameplay so I feel like now
if I'm posting sporadic gameplay
possibly on my main channel that to me
is more fun because I'm not sitting
there trying to do Let's Plays trying to
entertain now if I played for about 80
hours in Zelda I would probably take me
four times as long
to edit that footage so that doesn't
sound like fun to me unless I had an
editor which I don't smell he showed you
this little carrying case which is
actually really not that happy with it
[Music]
definitely on the hunt for a different
one
nice little cleaning cloth how real
problem is I can't stop playing and when
I do anything else I'm not enjoying
doing anything else except just thinking
about playing the game like today I had
to go somewhere at 3:45 today nude hit
and I was already on my fourth shrine of
the day making my way to another tower
and then at that point it was like 2:30
and I said girl you gotta go you got it
you gotta get up since a lot of you guys
have been requesting some game play fine
here here's a little bit I'll show you
what I got show you some things and
maybe we go try to find a shrine or two
or a tower I don't know all right we're
playing Zelda what have we got going on
here let's just take a look okay so it
says like played for 70 hours or more I
think I said 80 it feels like it
actually feels like I've played for six
months in the past two weeks so let's
hop into Zelda and let's take a peek I'm
not gonna do any spoilers but I am gonna
show my map I'm gonna show some of the
items that I have so if you don't want
to know anything about though then just
stop watching so it looks like I left
off here in this desert and something
super crazy what's happening to my map
earlier and that Sun is it is going down
super quick so here's my map a pretty
extensive world
I have almost everything unlocked it
looks like two possibly three more
regions unlocked I'm pretty sure this is
all one so I could be wrong
I could need two more towers this could
also be split up so maybe I need four
more I know this is a tower or a shrine
and this is also I think this is a tower
so it looks like these are probably
split so potentially I have four more
I've probably found about sixty shrines
I have let's see one two three
twelve hearts total I think I have let's
see here I think I can probably get
another heart container yes oh my god I
have seven spirit orbs this is exciting
because you need at least 13 to be able
to get your Master Sword so now I
can reclaim this for another heart
container I'll have 13 and then I could
go in and get that Master Sword baby I
don't really want to leave this area but
I kind of have to leave this area to
show you guys some more things I've got
a lot of tasks I have a mental list of
some things that I need to do and I'm
already forgetting those things I wish I
would have been actually taking physical
notes because there's so much stuff I
want to do so these are some of the
meals that I've cooked something that I
basically keep on hand at all times now
that I need full hearts is I just make
meat skewers I just load up five things
around me make those and I'm good to go
you can also sell those for a hundred
twenty rupees so I do like to make a lot
of those and just resell them these icy
meats are actually pretty great because
I will just use those if I kind of find
myself coming into contact with some
heat I don't have any armor that's heat
resistant yet that's on my to-do list
that's basically what my next task is
you usually get those by killing animals
out in the cold or throw some meat down
and it just instantly freezes and then
pick it back up so there's some my meals
I'd like to have some of the mid-level
defense at least because sometimes you
run into some big guys and I get scared
and that's what I have to do I have a
couple of diamonds which I'm pretty
excited about I think I have like five
or six oh seven five seven diamonds I
don't know if I'm gonna need them later
so I haven't been selling them or doing
anything I've just been kind of hoarding
them they Meebo been super helpful I
just like run through some amiibo if I
need some meats so here's my armor so
far the ones that I'm most proud of are
these I actually got them dyed pink
before I really realized what I was even
doing so I was like yeah this would be
cool waste of money like I did not need
to die those things stupid I've got our
Zora armors this allows us to swim
upstream I just got this one I'm trying
to find the bottom part so I need the
trousers to this set it's the climbing
gear climbing uses so much stamina and
it drives me nuts because I don't want
to unlock any stamina I want to keep my
heart's but I guess now that I can get
the Master Sword I guess I can allow
myself another stamina unlock I need
some more unlocks to I've just been on
the shrine grind bow and arrow is a
little I've an empty slot hopefully I
find something this
about to break so that's that uh I guess
oh my gosh so I don't want this to be a
spoiler but I'm gonna do it anyway when
you get into the desert you can freaking
ride sand seals kind of all God they've
run from you though come here there's
two of them okay I'm gonna be super
stealthy and I'm gonna run up and I'm
gonna grab this guy you need to have a
shield so you can surf if you haven't
shield surfed yet super cool now let
give me your body he's taking a little
nap but guess what give it your body
let's go let's get somewhere
take me somewhere baby no get away
there's a mean guy get away what are you
doing where are you running to okay okay
shut up I'm gonna transport over here to
the village I'm going to give myself a
heart container a little bit of rain
here leave me alone I've got things to
do like get myself my heart container
this is really big news guys I just want
you to know because now I can go try to
get that Master Sword may the goddess
smiled upon you yeah I'll bring peace
baby I'm so excited
this is such great news give me these
apples give me these
we need to cook some stuff up we had a
cook I can't cook because it's freaking
raining and there's no fire okay so I
think I've got enough maybe adventure
out just a little bit I would like to do
so I know there's a shrine that I did
not complete it was one of the a major
test of strength I don't think I
completed this one this is one that I
unlocked super early on and I was not
prepared for it at all so I had to drop
out and say hey we're gonna come back
when we've got more armor we've got more
hearts of Guardian was tough but I've
got a feeling I'm ready I could do this
let's do this let's do this I also need
to hit up some more of the fairy
fountains so that I can get my upgraded
armor because I've only hit up one so
far
I found three I still haven't found the
fourth a major test of strength this is
gonna be okay let me see what we've got
I should have enough items of god--and
okay don't want to use let's see
what do we have okay I've been loving
freezing this dude and then I have this
dual role armor I upgraded this we're
gonna put that on swim - stamina up oh
that's nice cool because I haven't come
back to this one because I knew I
couldn't do it so Oh God okay I'm not
ready memory memory I gotta pick what
else or what I want okay this is about
to die so we're just gonna we're gonna
click that okay ready I'm so nervous
it's so much easier now that I've
unlocked oh god where's my sword versus
war with my sword
did I throw it
[Music]
like this stasis is so incredible
especially against these ancient battle
ax is badly damaged this is not good
it's not good okay Oh
socks Thank you very
Oh God
oh geez oh boy okay hold on a second
okay I got to eat something I got to eat
something I gotta eat something I don't
think it's gonna take me long to beat
this guy so you're almost there shoot
[Music]
[Applause]
now
this is so nervous I'm so nervous
[Music]
I don't want to break my bigger weapons
because I don't have any money
I'm sweating bullets right now the
honest
[Music]
and then I want to use my arrows I want
to save them oh Jesus okay
[Music]
I'm gonna have to because I need to end
this right now
[Music]
we need to end this I can't I can't be
doing this anymore
[Music]
like oh she's oh god this means yes a
major type of strength give me
everything that you've got what am I
gonna get what am I getting what am I
gonna get what am I gonna get look at
all this good stuff okay oh that a
guardian shield plus plus huh oh man
wait I didn't get any I need some more
weapons kind of want to drop this one
but I really do need that guardian
shield because you need it to be able to
reflect the lasers later on I'm dropping
it cardian so nice baby nice nice nice
okay I also will take this Thank You
agent battle-ax hmm I really do want
that guardian shield don't I feel like I
should go back and get it but whatever
it's fine I'll be able to get another
one that's it guys that is that is a
major test of our strength so that I'm
finally strong enough to be able to beat
him the first time that I hopped up on
this dude I was like what this is
impossible cuz it was super early on how
do I get something a little bit better
though from it like I didn't really get
anything like good wow I can get another
heart container I gotta see if I can get
the Master Sword on 13 because if I can
then I'm totally fine doing that cuz I
do want to up my stamina really really
bad well I think that's it
guys I don't I don't know there's so
much I want to do there's so much I want
to do like I want to find everything I
want to know III oh gosh there's my
horse
I named him piggy I should probably put
him back in the stable cuz he's just out
there living life let's say guys let me
know if there's anything else you want
to know about Zelda or my gameplay if
you want to see some more gameplay I'll
post some I don't want to post like too
much because they also really hate
posting spoilers and then people get
upset about it and also I like to play
and then I have to like go back and edit
what I just played and then that means
that's less time that I could
spending playing this is where it is man
this is I got a guy gotta get in here I
gotta get in here I gotta get that sword
I can't I gotta get out I gotta go I
gotta go I gotta go I'll see you later
[Music]
during that entire unboxing video
I was super suspicious from the very
start this is not the handiwork of an
original unboxed iPhone I just want to
tell you and fortunately for myself but
fortunately for everyone else in the
world
I am extremely naive and I want to
believe